and then we do have today one
topic that is
still open that is the six sanctions
package
we've been working very hard and
successful with five sanctioned packages
already it's never been easy it's the
same now with the sixth package the
commission and the french presidency
have been working intensively in the
last days
to move forward on this package we are
not there yet
but it has matured for sure my
expectations are low that it will be
solved in the next 48 hours but i'm
confident that thereafter there will be
a possibility overall my call is very
clearly to
all member states we have one
key to success
and this is solidarity with ukraine and
unity of the european union just got the
text now and there is no agreement of
course the problem is you know that we
are in a very difficult situation
uh
basically because of the irresponsible
behavior of the commission
after uh diverse high consensus if you
agree that there will be no any
suggestion made by the commission on
energy which is not properly negotiated
with the member states and now out of
blue we have got the idea of uh of uh
embargo and sanctions on oil without
answering the questions which related to
the hungary and energy supply security
so the whole situation we are in is a is
a difficult one created by the
commission and the responsibility of not
having agreement today must be and will
be in the shoulder of the commission up
to now the first five sanctions package
was approached in a different way first
we made the sanctions and then we
started to think about the consequences
and looking for solutions but because
it's energy it's risky it's serious so
therefore we have to change our approach
first solutions
[Music]
[Music]
is for russia to lose the war
there is no compromise with russia
russia has to lose the war and we in
europe can help supplying arms to
ukraine so they can defend themselves
and push the russians back and broad
economic sanctions including oil
including gas to starve moscow of funds
this is the only way to move forward
i have argued from
the end of february when this war
started
full energy embargo coal oil and gas we
have coal sanctioned
tonight tomorrow i will be speaking
about oil sanctions i think that it's
very important that we sanction
russian oil because this is the huge
source of
the russian government's income is oil
and gas i also think we should sanction
gas
this is not going to feed the debate
today if each european country only
thinks about itself then we would never
move forward latvia is very heavily
dependent
has been on russian energy imports
we are moving away from that and have no
problem with that it's going to cost us
more but it's only money
the ukrainians are paying with their
lives and if if we get bogged down only
in thinking about money then what is the
sense of our union